[Musique]
c'est au cours de cette séance plénière
que les conseillers départementaux ont
adopté le budget primitif de la
collectivité pour l'aisne et 2021
un budget de plus de 1 milliard 159
millions qui est en augmentation de plus
de 63 millions d'euros par rapport à
2020 une marge budgétaire rendu possible
grâce à la recentralisation du rsa au
1er janvier 2020
un budget qui va intervenir au plus près
de tous les champs de compétence de la
collectivité
donc c'est un budget qui à la fois sera
consacré pour une bonne partie à nos
compétences obligatoires notamment dans
le secteur de l'action sociale de la
solidarité de l'insertion de l'éducation
de la jeunesse est aussi va y avoir une
forte composante en matière
d'investissements pour accélérer
l'investissement dans le secteur de
l'agriculture des routes des bâtiments
et tout ce qui contribue d'une manière
générale à la modernisation de
l'administration départementale et au
développement du territoire plus de 182
millions d'euros seront dégagés pour les
investissements soit une augmentation de
plus de 11% par rapport à 2020 des fonds
qui vous mettre en application la
relance économique et social ainsi que
la transition écologique et solidaire
porté par le département
aucune hausse de la fiscalité n'est
prévu ce qui va permettre à la fois de
faire plus de subventions également de
faire plus d'équipements et plus de
subventions d'équipement et
d'investissement sur le territoire et
c'est un budget aussi qui va nous
permettre de mettre en place des
dispositifs en 2021 pour soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat et accompagner les
acteurs du territoire dans leur action
face à la crise au cours de cette séance
plénière le département été félicité
pour sa campagne publicitaire de lutte
contre les addictions
le spot vidéo a reçu le prix excellence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]